how is cristian cásseres greeting you with
his new kirchner newscast in
spanish today marks the fourth anniversary of the
shooting at the 91 country rap music festival
58 people died after
a man shot two people from a
mandalay bay hotel and casino room years
later  more died from
injuries in the aftermath of this tragedy
state leaders like governor styps
were here police sheriff
attended the memorial service
friday morning
more sky a former voice performer
sang a song honoring the
victims  lost that day was written
by mark and self after one of
his friends was shot during the
october first massacre
the city of las vegas will also
pay tribute to the victims of
the friday night massacre inside
the healing garden  Mayor
Carmen gives the names of each life
lost that night aloud
the noise of the bell will be heard and
there will be a vigil with the environment full of
lit candles the ceremony will be at
10 pm in downtown las vegas
the goldeneye los vigueses will be
organizing a blood donation event
on friday inside the ceri
nationaux urine if you want to donate blood
they  they ask you to make an appointment on
the online page be sure to enter
the ge code here the golden knights
will also be handing out tickets
to the games and the warm
temperatures continue in the valley we will have
sunny skies to start the
weekend the lows will be  In the
sixties and the highs around the
90s I am Cristian Cásseres with his
informative prize of Spanish broadcast Good day